eine stadt bevölkert von sagenfiguren im
historischen zentrum von hameln tummeln
sich helden aus märchen und legenden und
jede menge hatten
sie erinnern an eine der berühmtesten
sagenfiguren deutschlands den
rattenfänger von hameln
der soll hier vor mehr als 700 jahren
sein unwesen getrieben haben und ist bis
heute vielen ein begriff wurde der
rattenfänger dank der sammlung der
brüder jacob und wilhelm grimm vor 200
jahren veröffentlichten sie einen band
mit zahlreichen erzählungen wie jener
über einen spielmann der hameln von
einer rattenplage befreite als er kein
geld bekam entführte er kurzerhand die
kinder mit seiner flötenmusik zwar gab
es schon früher überlieferungen aber die
berühmten märchensammler grimm machten
den rattenfänger international bekannt
die sage wurde in mehr als 30 sprachen
übersetzt
dadurch dass die brüder grimm auch mit
ihren anderen werken so populär sind hat
davon garten finger unglaublich
profitiert sehr populär ist ja im ganzen
angloamerikanischen bereich in europa
ohnehin auch in asien ist eine ganz
große rattenfänger und überhaupt märchen
und sagen begeisterung und davon
profitiert haben
jedes jahr kommen laut angaben der stadt
3,8 millionen menschen her um sich auf
die spuren des rattenfängers zu begeben
oder ihnen live zu erleben
michael bay ist seit 22 jahren
offizieller rattenfänger von hameln
der us amerikaner kennt die geschichte
noch aus kindertagen
ich hab schon der dritte schulklasse vom
rattenfänger gelesen und schon damals
die geschichte nicht geglaubt dass so
ein pfeiffer der kinder auch dann nicht
sein geld bekommt vom bürgermeister mit
einem magischen geschichte mit magische
musik und so dachte ich als ich erfuhr
dass es hameln hier tatsächlich gibt das
ist schön
ich lerne das findet der faszinierenden
geschichten der brüder grimm wurden in
kassel aufgeschrieben wo die brüder
lange lebten im interaktiven museum
grimm welt kann man ihren bekanntesten
figuren begegnen dem froschkönig
oder den sieben zwergen von
schneewittchen doch jacob und wilhelm
grimm waren mehr als nur märchensammler
die studierten juristen waren auch
politiker und sie begannen das deutsche
wörterbuch zu erstellen
ein mammutprojekt das erst nach ihrem
tod fertig wurde
sie haben dieses alte kulturgut die
märchen und die sagen gesammelt haben
das in eine gemeinsame frauen gebraucht
und haben damit ein werk geschaffen was
dann auch zu der großen verbreitung
weltweit beigetragen hat die geschichten
haben viele künstler inspiriert und
wurden auf dem kino gezeigt ob früher
als scherenschnitt oder als
animationsfilm wie hier der gestiefelte
kater
bis heute greift vor allem hollywood auf
die märchen der brüder grimm zurück wie
kürzlich mit dem oscar nominierten
cinderella einer modernen aschenputtel
version
auch die rattenfänger sage wurde oft auf
die leinwand gebracht
bekannt ist der disney zeichentrickfilm
von 1933
doch was unterscheidet eigentlich die
sage von einem märchen sagen haben immer
mindestens einen historischen bezug wie
man zum beispiel rattenfänger sage in
hameln gut feststellen kann
das hat hier wirklich gespielt so oder
so ähnlich
doch ob nun sage oder märchen vor allem
bei kindern kommen die geschichten der
brüder grimm an
auch nach mehr als 200 jahren